Boa noite a todos é um prazer estar com
vocês novamente numa Live um assunto
muito importante um assunto muito
cativante
é dos assuntos que eu mais gosto eu acho
interessantíssimo e a gente vai então
falar desse tema sendo o mais objetivo
possível passando para você informações
relevantes Sem enrolação e logo em
seguida vamos responder às dúvidas de
vocês ao
vivo Então temos várias dúvidas já
colocadas aqui no chat né então a gente
vai ter bastante assunto aqui para
discutir e eu gostaria que vocês por
favor fossem me falando como é que está
o áudio se o áudio Está ok Se vocês me
ouvem
bem Se tiver algum problema aí de áudio
me avisem por favor
tá boa noite Eliseu Boa noite André Sara
Estou aguardando o feedback mas já vou
iniciar a exposição então o tema de hoje
é o intestino Hiper permeável no inglês
é conhecido como liut em português fica
estranho né intestino que vaza Esse é um
assunto extremamente importante para nós
todos porque cada vez mais esse é um
problema mais prevalente mais pessoas
sofrem disso e por quê Por causa da
intoxicação ambiental poluentes
por causa dos medicamentos por causa dos
hábitos alimentares alimentos
processados industrializados por causa
do stresse nós vamos discutir isso ao
longo dessa Live Sara Gabriela Irani ou
Irani que estão acompanhando por favor
Vânia também boa noite a todos vocês por
favor me deem o feedback se o áudio está
bom Se vocês me escutam bem
ok então a síndrome do intestino
permeável também conhecido como liqu gut
é uma situação é uma condição que afeta
o revestimento do
intestino causando danos e aumentando a
permeabilidade a Vânia tá dando um
feedback aqui que o áudio Está bom Está
ótimo que bom já temos dois feedbacks
aqui da Silvana e da Irani do Eliseu
também e da Sara então podemos continuar
Ok então em o intestino saudável as
paredes intestinais atuam como uma
barreira seletiva então permite que os
nutrientes essenciais possam ser
absorvidos na corrente sanguínea
Enquanto ao bloqueio a passagem de
substâncias ruins potencialmente
prejudiciais quando o intestino se torna
hiper permeável
essa barreira protetora ela é
comprometida e isso permite que as
toxinas bactérias partículas de
alimentos que não foram digeridos ainda
passem pelo intestino paraa corrente
sanguínea e isso é ruim e já vou
explicar
Porquê essa permeabilidade intestinal
aumentada pode desencadear uma série de
problemas de saúde Já que as substâncias
que escapam do intestino podem provocar
uma resposta inflamatória no corpo então
a síndrome intestino permeável tem sido
associado a uma variedade de condições
de doenças Isso inclui problemas
digestivos ou digestórios Fadiga Crônica
dores nas articulações problemas de pele
problemas até de cérebro o chamado fogue
mental a Néa mental e até mesmo doenças
autoimunes a mais comum o
rimoto então quando toxinas e bactérias
entram na corrente sanguínea o sistema
de defesa o sistema imune ou imunológico
pode reagir de forma exagerada levando a
inflamação no corpo inteiro nós chamamos
de inflamação sistêmica e ao
desenvolvimento de várias doenças Então
embora síndrome intestino permeável não
seja amplamente reconhecido ainda pela
comunidade médica Ortodoxa ou
tradicional tem muitas evidências são
evidências crescentes que sugerem que
ela desempenha um papel significativo na
saúde geral muitos profissionais de
saúde que fazem saúde funcional
integrativa como eu com consideram aina
no intestino permeável demais ou hiper
permeável como um fator que vai
contribuir para uma série de doenças de
condições crônicas que afetam milhões de
pessoas em todo o
mundo temos um comentário aqui da
Gabriela que eu vou falar agora porque é
pertinente ó Doutor o liqu gante no meu
caso causava e tiroidite de Hashimoto em
chaque ca tirei o glúten da dieta e
estou curada graças a Deus Gabriela fico
muito feliz porque realmente o glúten é
um dos fatores que levam ao liqu gante
conforme nós vamos falar ao longo dessa
Live então Vamos explorar as causas da C
intestino permeável ou hiper permeável
vamos falar dos fatores dietéticos já
falamos aqui brevemente do glúten vamos
também nos aprofundar nisso além da
dieta existe o estresse as infecções que
pode ser viral bacteriana fúngica ou
parasitária ou eitos né são aquelas
parasit das grandes medicamentos e
desequilíbrios na Flora na microbiota
intestinal vamos discutir também
modificações que nós podemos fazer nos
hábitos de vida de saúde e suplementos
que poderam ajudar a tratar e prevenir
essa situação bem como um plano de ação
abrangente para restaurar a saúde
intestinal então ao compreender a cin
intestino irritável desculpa não c
intestino irritável mas também tem a ver
com isso mas estamos falando hoje do
intestino hiper permeável então ao
compreender a síndrome do intestino
hiper permeável e suas implicações paraa
saúde podemos tomar medidas proativas
para poder promover o intestino saudável
melhorar o bem-estar geral né Vamos
falar das causas
então diversos fatores Já comecei a
falar desses fatores dessas causas podem
contribuir pro desenvolvimento da no
intestino hiper permeável comprometendo
então a integridade da barreira
intestinal primeiro uma dieta pobre rica
em alimentos processados
industrializados inflamatórios como
açúcares e glúten podem danificar o
revestimento intestinal esses alimentos
podem desencadear uma resposta
inflamatória no intestino V enfraquecer
as junções celulares né
os chamadas tight junctions né no inglês
tá que mantém a barreira intestinal
intacta por exemplo o consumo excessivo
de alimentos processados e açúcares
refinados podem levar a um desequilíbrio
na microbiota fazendo crescer algumas
espécies e outras espécies vão diminuir
Então vai ter esse
desequilíbrio isso vai favorecer então o
crescimento de bactérias prejudiciais e
elas vão produzir substâncias tóxicas
capazes de danificar o revestimento
intestinal Outro fator fora o alimentar
É o estresse crônico é muito importante
é muito significativo para a síndrome do
intestino hiper permeável quando o corpo
está sob estresse constante a produção
de cortisol no primeiro momento aumenta
e fica alta pode depois cair se esse
stresse fica muito tempo mas quando esse
cortisol aumenta no stresse aguda o que
pode acontecer é que ele enfraquece o
sistema imune porque o cortisol ele tem
ação imuno eh supressora isso vai
perturbar a microbiota intestinal e essa
perturbação vai levar a inflamação e
aumento da permeabilidade intestinal
Além disso O stresse pode alterar a
motilidade do intestino tanto para
constipação quanto para diarreia ou seja
aumentar ou diminuir a motilidade e pode
também reduzir o fluxo sanguíneo pro
trato digestório comprometendo ainda
mais a saúde intestinal tem algumas
perguntas que foram colocadas aqui no
início que eu não vou responder ainda
vou deixar pro final porque são
perguntas que faz mais sentido responder
Depois da exposição Total Ok mas eu
posso ler alguns comentários aqui e a
gente fazer algumas considerações aqui
de coisas que não são perguntas mais
avançadas Então pessoal infecções
bacterianas virais ou
parasitárias também podem causar
inflamação e danos ao revestimento
intestinal então quando acontece dos
patógenos né dos bichos ruim né falar
num gaj bem simples aqui né esses bichos
invadem o intestino eles podem
desencadear uma Resposta imune que
resulta inflamação e aumento da
permeabilidade por exemplo uma infecção
para um bicho aí comum que dá muita
intoxicação alimentar o salmonela né dá
muita diarreia vômito então a salmonela
pode levar a OC colite que dá vômito da
diarreia causa inflamação e Danos às
Paredes intestinais Além disso o uso de
medicamentos como antiinflamatórios não
esteroidais Quais são esses nimesulid
declofenaco
Ibuprofeno esses antiinflamatórios
comuns que vocês conhecem eles podem
irritar o revestimento intestinal e
contribuir para a síndrome do intestino
excessivamente permeável Então os
antiinflamatórios esteroidais que são
essa classe de antiinflamatórios comuns
que você compra sem receita na farmácia
eles reduzem a produção de muco que
protege o intestino e torna o intestino
mais vulnerável a danos e
inflamação mais uma situação o super
crescimento bacteriano Já perguntaram
aqui já vou responder o cibo é uma
condição em que há um desequilíbrio na
microbiota intestinal com um crescimento
excessivo de certas bactérias também
pode desempenhar um papel no
desenvolvimento da síndrome int
permeável Então já tô respondendo aqui à
dúvida da Sara que ela perguntou se CBO
tem relação com o Lick Gut Tem sim Sara
tem relação com Lick Gut por essa razão
que eu tô falando aqui ok
Ah então vamos
continuar então quando há um crescimento
exagerado ou excessivo de bactérias
prejudiciais no intestino delgado elas
vão produzir Toxin e substâncias vão
danificar o revestimento intestinal
levando a inflamação e aumento da
permeabilidade fatores que acontecem no
início da vida como exposição a
antibióticos na infância na primeira
infância ou crianças que nasceram por
parto cesariano em vez de ser parto
normal não tiveram contato suficiente
com a flora da mãe E aí não foram
colonizadas com a flora da mãe que é
predominantemente de lactobacilos né
quando a o bebê passa pelo canal vaginal
pelo canal do parto ele acaba engolindo
as bactérias que tem naquela região da
mãe n Apesar que você alguém possa
pensar que iso é nojento na verdade isso
é muito bom pra saúde do bebê que vai
ser colonizado então crianças que
nasceram de pá cesariano não tiveram
essa oportunidade de serem colonizadas
fta disposição a uma diversidade de
bactérias crianças de apartamento que
não brinca só fica no videogame só fica
no celular só fica no YouTube essas
crianças não são expostas né a uma
variedade maior de bactérias as que elas
TM no solo e também não tem essa
variedade toda e podem estar expostas a
a situação do liqu gante do intestino
hiper permeável isso tudo pode impactar
a saúde intestinal a longo prazo uso de
antibióticos pode eliminar não só as
bactérias ruins que muitas vezes é
necessário você dar antibiótico né mas
infelizmente esses antibióticos vão
também eliminar as bactérias boas
benéficas que protegem o revestimento
intestinal então bebês nascidos por
cesariana né já comentei isso não são
expostos às bactérias benéficas do canal
isso vai afetar o desenvolvimento da sua
própria microbiota intestinal além disso
a falta de Exposição à variedade de
bactérias através do contato com animais
Então as crianças às vezes né hoje em
dia tem muito animal doméstico né as
pessoas têm bastante cachorro e gato mas
digamos uma criança que não tem contato
com nenhum tipo de animal e seria
interessante ter contato com animais de
fazenda por exemplo né e não só animais
domésticos que podem também estar com
uma situação de
disbiose então a falta de contato com
essa variedade de bactérias e da
brincadeira ao ar livre que também leva
a a ter contato com isso pode limitar o
desenvolvimento de uma microbiota
intestinal diversa e saudável aumentando
o risco então da assim o intestino hiper
permeável
posteriormente na vida então como é que
nós fazemos eu tô sendo bem objetivo
aqui pessoal para depois responder as
perguntas de vocês tá tô falando básico
que que é o mais essencial de entender
então para tratar a síndrome intestino
impermeável é importante é crucial fazer
certas mudanças estilo de vida uma das
modificações mais importantes é seguir
uma dieta que promova a cicatrização do
intestino então isso envolve o quê focar
em alimentos
integrais alimentos naturais não
processados frutas especialmente com
casca vegetais proteínas magras gorduras
saudáveis então alimentos que são
inflamatórios como é o caso do glúten
dos laticínios porque a caseína que tem
no leite derivado dos laticínios também
é dá problema na barreira intestinal
porque ele imita o glúten a caseína
imita o glúten tá caseína não tem nada a
ver com lactose tô falando aqui da
proteína uma das proteínas do leite que
tem essa ação
inflamatória não é a proteína que tá no
soro do leite mas a proteína que tá na
parte que decanta quando você vai fazer
o queijo tá que é a caseína essa
proteína é inflamatória assim como
glúten certo além de você tirar esses
alimentos inflamatórios processados
refinados açúcar glúten Laticínios entra
com a dieta antiinflamatória tem várias
dietas antiinflamatórias por exemplo a
mais conhecida dieta do Mediterrâneo tem
mais específicas como a dieta
paleolítica a dieta paleolítica na
variação autoimune que é uma é um
subtipo de dieta paleolítica mais
restrita e a dieta baixa em fodmap tá
essa siga fodmap significa vários tipos
de substâncias que fermentam tá no
intestino tá que são os sacarídeos
dissacarídeos monossacarídeos polióis tá
são várias substâncias que fermento
então essas dietas que eu acabei de
mencionar são exemplos de dietas
favoráveis ao intestino que podem ajudar
a reduzir a inflamação e promover a
cicatrização então além da dieta o
gerenciamento do estresse é muito
importante para tratar essa síndrome o
estresse crônico pode enfraquecer o
sistema imune perturbar a microbiota int
inal então piorando a condição da
hiperpermeabilidade intestinal então
podemos usar técnicas de redução do
stress tem várias né como meditação
respiração
profunda
exercícios específicos taiuan
ticum yoga
mindfulness todos eles podem
ajudar acalmar o sistema nervoso central
promover a saúde intestinal temos a
situação do eix intestino cérebro que é
uma via de Mão Dupla aqui vai para cá
para cá vai para lá então cérebro ruim
dá intestino ruim intestino ruim dá cé
ruim tá então é uma via de Mão Dupla
dormir o suficiente coisa que muita
gente não faz né A maioria das pessoas
dormem mal é crucial dormir bem pois a
falta de sono pode aumentar a inflamação
prejudicar a função do sistema imune
então
precisa dormir de 7 A 9 horas no mínimo
7 horas por noite algumas pessoas melhor
ainda que dam nove tá e tem que ser um
sono de alta qualidade na maioria das
noites manter-se bem hidratado ou bem
hidratada é muito importante tomar 2 l
2,5 L se for uma pessoa pequena pode
tomar 1,5 L Mas vai ser entre 1,5 l e
2,5 L é importante para apoiar dar
suporte a digestão eliminar
toxinas além das mudanças de estilo de
vida certos suplementos podem ajudar a
tratar a sí intestino hiper permeável
probióticos são
eh suplementos que podem ajudar não
sempre ajudam pessoas que TM cibo Às
vezes o probiótico vai piorar a situação
cibo é aquela proliferação de bactérias
no intestino delgado Às vezes o
probiótico aumenta ainda mais a
quantidade de fermentação a pessoa tem
mais gases mais desconforto e mais e
alteração do hábito intestinal então
probiótico às vezes funciona muito e às
vezes não funciona porém que que são
probióticos para quem não sabe são
bactérias benéficas que ajudam a manter
uma microbiota intestinal saudável as
cepas mais comuns são os lactobacilos e
bifidobacterium de várias espécies para
algumas pessoas lactobacilos e bif
bactério não vai ser bacana E aí você
pode usar os soil based organisms que
são os sbo são
os probióticos baseados no solo que a
maioria eles são
eh bacilos tá são bacilos que fazem eh
encistamento por exemplo com bacilos
coagulans por exemplo é um desses bichos
aí então ah algumas pessoas que têm
intestino em pmav vão se dar bem com
probióticos comuns com lactobacilos e
bif bacterium outros vão precisar de spo
então é um caso que tem que ser
analisado né individualmente né
particularmente cada caso enzimas
digestivas também vão ajudar bastante ao
quebrar as partículas de alimento
ajudando então a não ter tantas
proteínas mal digeridas que podem ah
gerar o liqu gate o intestino hiper
permeável Então vai ajudar a quebrar os
alimentos reduzir a inflamação no
intestino essas enzimas e a helig
Glutamina que é o aminoácido vai ajudar
a reparar e fortalecer o revestimento
intestinal os ácidos grassos ômega-3
encontrados em peixes gordurosos e
suplementos tem propriedades também de
cicatrização
antiinflamatórias podem ajudar a reduzir
a inflamação do intestino a vitamina D
de dado também importante para a saúde
intestinal Pois dá apoio à função imune
ajuda a manter a integridade da barreira
intestinal Então como é que a gente
começa a fazer essas mudanças Para
incorporar essas modificações e
suplementos é bom começar fazendo
mudanças graduais na sua dieta no estilo
de vida para ficar mais suave para ficar
mais sustentável substitua alimentos
processados por alternativas integrais
adicione mais frutas e vegetais à suas
refeições Estabeleça uma rotina
gerenciamento do
estresse reservando mais tempo para
atividades relaxantes e exercícios
regulares considere adicionar
suplementos à sua rotina diária
começando com probióticos mas aí é bom
que você tenha uma orientação
profissional porque pode dá errado
dependendo do tipo de probiótico e
enzimas digestivas né então é importante
consultar um médico que entenda desse
assunto ou um nutricionista Antes de
iniciar qualquer novo suplemento
especialmente se você tiver condições
médicas pré-existentes ou estiver
tomando medicamentos é importante se
lembrar de que tratar ain intestino
hiper permeável é um processo gradual e
às vezes toma muito tempo tem casos
difíceis de lidar e a pessoa à vez não
tem paciência e às vezes o processo
demora até anos tá tem que ter muita
paciência e muita consistência então ao
fazer mudanças sustentáveis na sua dieta
no seu estilo de vida incorporar
suplementos direcionados você pode dar
suporte cicatrização do seu intestino
melhorar a sua saúde geral Então tem um
plano de ação de oito passos né para uma
abordagem abrangente no tratamento da C
intestino irritável Desculpa falei de
novo irritável quis dizer hiper
permeável tá é porque essa esse termo
fica muito na cabeça então para você ter
essa abordagem abrangente no tratamento
da C do intestino permeável ou hiper
permeável vamos fazer o plano de oito
etapas que são essas oito etapas são
etapas que vão visar restaurar a saúde
intestinal de forma gradual de forma
sustentável primeira etapa número um é
redefinir a dieta e o estilo de vida
eliminando os alimentos inflamatórios
adotando hábitos saudáveis em seguida dá
suporte ao intestino com probióticos
enzimas digestivas para promover uma
microbiota intestinal equilibrada e
melhorar a digestão então o primeiro
ponto não é iniciar suplemento é mudar a
dieta e mudar o estilo de vida Aí sim
você pode muitas vezes aí tem que ver
também esse a segunda etapa de entrar
com probiótico enzima digestiva Às vezes
você não pode entrar direto com
probiótico aí que entra a orientação do
profissional de saúde do médico
nutricionista muitas vezes você tem que
tomar
fitoterápicos para matar as bactérias
que estão proliferando se tiver um cibo
ou até mesmo antibióticos e depois que
tiver reduzida a população de bactérias
aí você entra assim com probióticos e as
enzimas digestivas já podem entrar
direto não tem por que esperar então
etapa número um mudança estilo de vida
mudança da dieta redução do estresse
atividade física tomar água sono
adequado tudo isso que vocês conhecem
número dois enzimas digestivas e em
muitos casos você vai entrar com
antibióticos naturais ou até mesmo
antibióticos não naturais em alguns
casos terceiro ponto remoção de
bactérias indesejadas tá então já falei
isso no segundo ponto porque você pode
inverter em alguns em alguns casos você
pode começar com probiótico e outros
casos você começar com antibiótico tá
então eh a terceira etapa pode virar a
segunda e a segunda virar a terceira
então remover as bactérias indesejadas
usando tanto antimicrobianos naturais
quanto os
antibióticos então após a remoção dessas
bactérias periciais temos que
reequilibrar a microbiota intestinal com
os probióticos e os prebióticos tá o
prebiótico é o que é a fibra tá são
aquela parte dos alimentos que a gente
não consegue digerir com nossas enzimas
e as bactérias digerem elas conseguem
comer e a gente não come então Eh Por
exemplo quando você come vegetais quando
você
come mesmo Arroz ele tem fibra e essa
fibra que vai alimentar as bactérias
Então a próxima etapa envolve a
reintrodução gradual de alimentos
eliminados tá que na no primeira etapa
quando você tá comendo eh a dieta mais
limpa você vai eliminar vários alimentos
que possam estar irritando tá mas você
não vai reintroduzir por exemplo o
glúten ou leite eu não recomendo que
reintroduce poderiam est tendo algum
problema aí você pode fazer um exame de
intolerância
alimentar por exemplo pode dar um
problema no ovo na amendoim na soja e
você pode reintroduzir algum desses
alimentos que foram eliminados
anteriormente monitorando cuidadosamente
as reações do corpo né Se tiver reação
você suspende de novo aquele alimento tá
sendo reintroduzido na próxima etapa que
é a sexta etapa
eh você pode introduzir o amido
resistente tá que no caso tem a batata
quando você cozinha ela e põe ela para
resfriar se forma um amido resistente
então a batata doce também o arroz
também então você pode reintroduzir isso
daí para ajudar a crescer as bactérias
boas
ok Então a próxima etapa que é a Sétima
Etapa é diminuição gradual dos
Suplementos à medida que a saúde
intestinal melhora e a última etapa
oitava etapa Se concentra na manutenção
das melhorias com o plano de manutenção
personalizado então gente essas etapas
elas podem mudar de posição isso é muito
individual para cada pessoa então o
importante é primeiro tirar os alimentos
inflamatórios e segunda etapa você
limpar o intestino das bactérias ruim se
for necessário próxima etapa você você
dá as bactérias boas de volta e os
prebióticos e depois você fazer um
desmame dos Suplementos
Ok então além do tratamento a prevenção
doino intestino permeável ou hip
permeável é importante então você tem
que tratar e depois prevenir para ela
não voltar mais uma das estratégias de
prevenção é evitar o uso desnecessário
de antibióticos que podem perturbar o
equilíbrio da flora intestinal quando os
antibióticos são necessários é
importante restaurar a microbiota
intestinal depois de utilizá-los você
pode usar probióticos E prebióticos para
isso amamentar os bebês né Vocês que são
mães ou conhecem alguém que é mãe é uma
forma eficaz de
apoiar então amamentar os bebês também
uma forma eficaz dar suporte ao
desenvolvimento de uma microbiota
intestinal saudável já que o leite
materno contém prebióticos e anticorpos
que protegem o intestino o bebê Além
disso expor as crianças a uma ampla Gama
de bactérias deixando elas brincarem no
ar livre ter contato com terra com grama
com animais isso é importante para
desenvolver uma microbiota intestinal
diversa e robusta reduzindo o risco de
sí de intestino permeável então é
importante ressaltar que o tratamento da
sí intestino hi permeável ele tem que
ser personalizado como eu falei por isso
que às vezes você tem que inverter a
ordem dos procedimentos para atender as
necessidades circunstâncias únicas de
cada indivíduo então trabalhar com
profissional de saúde como
médico mesmo médico funcional ou um
gastro funcional se você tiver acesso
pode ajudar a desenvolver um plano de
tratamento abrangente eficaz os
profissionais vão poder orientar sobre
modificações na dieta no estilo de vida
recomendar suplementos específicos
monitorar o processo e o progresso ao
longo do tempo então ao colaborar com
profissional de saúde experiente os
indivíduos com cimo intestino IP
permeável
podem receber o apoio e a orientação
necessárias para restaurar a saúde
intestinal e melhorar a qualidade de
vida
então essa conclusão aqui que eu
elaborei também eu vou deixar para falar
no final tá pra gente fechar o assunto
então deixa eu começar a responder às
dúvidas pergunta o glúten antes da
reforma agrícola também provocava
intestino
impermeável essa é uma boa pergunta
então a resposta dessa pergunta é o
seguinte
eh no
começo existia um trigo que não era
feita uma seleção natural
desse trigo e nem tinha também
manipulação genética Então esse trigo
tinha pouquíssimo glúten e ele era muito
mais saudável além dele ter muito mais
fibra com tempo com a modificação com
com os cruzamentos genéticos no começo
depois com a manipulação de Engenharia
Genética a o teor de glúten dos
alimentos aumentou bastante e isso levou
a uma pior da situação que antes era bem
mais suave juntando com a questão do
estresse dos medicamentos e das
substâncias tóxicas que tem no meio
ambiente metal pesado por exemplo Então
hoje o liqu gante é muito mais
prevalente do que era há 40 ou 50 anos
atrás Glutamina pode ser um excelente
suplemento mas não dá para dizer que ele
é o melhor isso é individual tá
Eliseu prebióticos pioram o intestino
impermeável depende tá não há evidências
conclusivas que os prebióticos pioram o
intestino impermeável alguns estudos na
verdade sugerem que certos prebióticos
podem até ajudar a melhorar a
integridade da barreira porém pessoas
que T cibo que tem proliferação de
bactéria no intestino Delgado podem não
tolerar bem alguns tipos de fibras pode
aumentar os gases e o desconforto
abdominal Então tem que ser uma coisa
individual
Ok então pessoas que têm intestino com
super crescimento bacteriano ou pessoas
que têm doença de cron e culitos cativa
No começo é recomendado fazer uma dieta
com baixa fibra até que tenha uma
reversão de esse super crescimento
bacteriano para depois entrar com
prebiótico e talvez
probiótico quais medicamentos provocam o
intestino hiper permeável São vários
antiinflamatórios não esteroidais como
eu já falei buprofeno Naproxeno também
aspirina tá então esses
antiinflamatórios eles provocam aumento
da pemi habilidade intestinal
antibióticos também já comentei isso daí
um que eu não comentei ainda que sãoos
prazois inibidores de bomba de próton
eles provocam sim eh hiperpermeabilidade
tem tanta gente hoje tomando isso daí
durante anos né e é um problema sério
quimioterapia medicamentos pesados assim
para doença autoimune imunossupressores
anticoncepcionais orais também podem dar
problema corticoides né que são
antiinflamatórios não Estero aliás são
antiinflamatórios esteroidais os
corticoides eles também podem provocar
piora da barreira e a metiformina em
alguns casos pode causar alteração de
filidade intestinal
Ok Há alguma coisa na aparência da
pessoa que a gente possa bater o olho e
dizer com certeza não certeza não mas
tem suspeitas tá pessoas que T muita
problema de pele que tem por
exemplo é muita descamação na pele lesão
avermelhada na pele tá pessoas que têm
eh e problemas assim de diarreia ou
constipação você pode suspeitar de
intestino hiper permear pessoas que tem
problema de articulação d na articulação
você pode suspeitar
também pessoas que têm dificuldade de
concentração você pode também suspeitar
mas certeza só vai ter investigando né
Essa pessoa no
consultório deficiência de vitaminas
provoca intestino Hi permeável sim
deficiência de vitamina D que é
importante pra barreira intestinal
deficiência de vitamina A também que é
importante e algumas vitaminas do
complexo B como o ácido fólico a
vitamina B12 elas são importantes paraa
saúde intestinal mineral zinco também é
importante especialmente aí pra saúde do
estômago mas também pra barreira
intestinal o magnésio também é
importante paraas ti junction nas
junções estreitas lá do intestino a
vitamina C é importante por ser um
antioxidante ah intestino hiper
permeável dificulta as coisas para
combater a dengue
sim pode piorar o combate a dengue
também ao covid tá porque o intestino
IMP permeável ele atrapalha a resposta
de defesa A Resposta imune permite a
passagem de toxinas bactérias e
partículas de alimentos isso pode
sobrecarregar o sistema de defesa e
atrapalhar a capacidade de combater a
dengue então A inflamação crônica também
provocada pelo liqu gante pode
enfraquecer mais a o sistema imune E
também o desequilíbrio da microbiota
intestinal pode atrapalhar também o
sistema de defesa imune Além da questão
da ma absorção de nutrientes que podde
vir com liqu
Gut pode também atrapalhar
ok basicamente isso
daí se a pessoa comer alimentos
inflamatórios todo dia quanto tempo leva
para ter intestino permeável muito
variável Tá mas um estudo diz que uma
única refeição rica em gordura eh que
não seja gordura saudável né gordura
artificial pode aumentar a pmid
intestinal dentro de 1 a 4 horas após o
consumo outro estudo descobriu que uma
dieta ocidental rica em gorduras ruins e
açúcares refinados pode ter Impacto
dentro de uma semana em pessoas
saudáveis e para a maioria das pessoas
pode ser de duas a seis semanas esse
processo de aumento de permeabilidade
e quanto tempo leva para reverter
depende muito tá é muito variável isso
daí depende da gravidade da condição a
consistência à dieta saudável aderência
né e outras situações de saúde que possa
estar junto
subjacentes então teve um estudo que
mostrou que uma dieta baixa em fodmap
reduziu esse excesso de permeabilidade
intestinal em cerca de 4 Semanas um
outro estudo que mostrou que a doença
celíaca ligado aí ao glúten e quando foi
retirado o glúten essa peridade
intestinal Demorou de se a 12 meses para
reverter ou seja por causa do da doença
celí que é eh Rara graças a Deus demora
bem mais tá então é semanas tá a gente
pode dizer que a reversão acontece em
semana de quatro semanas em
diante bariat possuem intestino IP pável
com mais facilidade
sim pessoas que passaram por cirurgia
bariátrica especialmente que fizeram Y
de ru que é um um bipés uma derivação
tem isso aumentado desenvolver o liqu
Gut várias razões alterações anatômicas
ma absorção de nutrientes alterações na
microbiota intestinal porque esse
pessoal pode desenvolver uma disbiose
crônica inflamação eh generalizada e os
medicamentos que os bariátricos podem
ter que precisar tomar como alguns eh
tomam por exemplo prazois né inibidores
da bomba de próton isso como eu já falei
pode piorar a situação do intestino
hiper permeável
isso aqui Eu já respondi sim eh cibo tem
relação com o liqu Gut né cibo é uma das
causas de liqu
Gut Qual o melhor exame para ver aspecto
do intestino hiper permeável
antes de passar para essa pergunta eh
além do cibo causar o liquigas intestino
impermeável o próprio intestino
impermeável pode causar cibo tá então é
uma via de Mão Dupla também tá então o
intestino impermeável permite que
toxinas bactérias e partículas e
alimentos que não foram digeridos
totalmente entrem na corrente sanguínea
o que pode sobrecarregar o sistema de
defesa imune e levar a inflamação
sistêmica e essa inflamação pode
prejudicar mo utilidade do intestino e a
função das válvulas secis isso permite
que as bactérias do Colon podem voltar
pro Delgado causando
cibo Qual o melhor exame para ver
aspectos do intestino hiper permeável tá
tem um teste que não é muito comum no
Brasil que é o teste permeabilidade
intestinal com lactulose e Manitol é um
teste mais direto você ingere uma
solução contendo lactulose e Manitol e
você vai coletar a urina por várias
horas e presença de níveis elevados de
lactol na urina isso indica aumento da
permeabilidade intestinal também você
pode fazer um exame de coprológico
funcional estendido que você pode medir
marcadores aí que é a zonulina aumento
da zonulina indica a presença de liqu
Gut então tem testes indiretos também
sorológicos de sangue né que você pode
buscar anticorpos contra a gliadina
contra o glúten anticorpos contra
caseína pode buscar também
lipopolissacarídeos bacterianos eh de
copos contra os lipopolissacarídeos
bacterianos isso também não é comum é
uma coisa mais difícil de
conseguir E aí então é basicamente isso
agora também tem testes também que não
são específicos como proteína ser
reativa no sangue pode aumentar com liqu
gante It leucina 6 fator de necrose
tumoral Alfa que são marcadores de
inflamação sistêmica podem indicar de
maneira indireta e não específica que
pode ser um caso de Lick gut e a
calprotectina fecal que você pode ser
feito junto com o coprológico estendido
ele é um marcador de Formação intestinal
né que não é diretamente um marcador de
liqu gante mas geralmente está aumentado
nesses casos
Ok tem uns testes também de microbioma
intestinal que você pode fazer eu não
gosto muito desses testes Mas eles podem
mostrar a disbiose e podem sugerir de
uma maneira indireta que tem o liqu
gante ok
e existe o teste também de cibo né que
não é de liqu gante de cibo que é o
teste de hidrogênio inspirado que pode
mostrar que a pessoa tem o cibo que
muitas vezes tá associado ao liqu Gut e
endoscopia digestiva alta e colonoscopia
pode ajudar também em caso que você tem
suspeita que tem doença de crom ou que
tem retocolite ser ativa
eh ela vai se livrar dos sintomas aos
pouquinhos eliz eu não é uma coisa super
rápida não tá é uma coisa
gradual intolerância a estamina tem a
ver sim tá com a questão do liqu Gut
eles estão intimamente relacionados a
estamina é uma mina biogênica ela
desempenha um papel importante muitos
processos ela não tá só presente pessoal
na alergia como muitas pessoas pensam a
pessoa pode ter uma liberação de
estamina sem ter alergia tá porque a
estamina é importante pra Resposta imune
paraa neurotransmissão ele é um
neurotransmissor estamina ela regula a
permeabilidade
intestinal então o intestino hiper
permeável pode causar intolerância
estamina porque ele permite que grandes
quantidades de estamina dos alimentos
entre na corrente sanguínea isso pode
sobrecarregar as enzimas que tem na
borda de escova que degradam a estamina
a principal delas é o o da né
diaminoxidase
e no sangue tem uma enzima também
importante chamada histamina en
metiltransferase
e se você tem também uma deficiência
dessa enzima leva o acúmulo de estamina
no corpo então níveis elevados de
estamina vão dar sintomas de
intolerância como erupções na pele
Diarreia dor de cabeça hipotensão tem
muitos sintomas do liqu gante tem
eh correlação tá estreitamente
relacionado à intolerância estam Ok
então pessoas também que começaram com
inerência histamínica podem gerar também
o intestino hiper permeável então uma
mão de é uma via de Mão Dupla de novo
como eu falei no caso ali do do cibo né
então a estamina ela aumenta a peridade
intestinal ág noos receptores H1 e H2 do
intestino em pessoas que TM tolerância
vitamina o excesso de vitamina pode
comprometer a integridade da barreira
intestinal levando essa intestino Hi
permeável né
então a inflamação provocado pela
resposta imunológica estamina também
pode danificar mais ainda a barreira
intestinal tá então tem uma relação bem
É uma pergunta muito boa da Sara
inclusive ozon terapia cura o intestino
hiper permeável não Eliseu Mas pode
ajudar Ok ajudar a reduzir inflamação
ã dos mais elevadas de vitamina D pode
favorecer o intestino Sim eu já comentei
isso que é uma das substâncias que
ajudam a barreira intestinal além da
vitamina A do zinco do magnésio que eu
comentei aqui boa noite a todos que
estão dando boa noite para
mim isso aqui eu já comentei Josi se
você não escutou depois Veja a parte do
vídeo que eu comentei isso vai ficar
gravado isso que eu já comentei também
parabéns Gabriela por ter se melhorado
da da enxaque que tem a ver também é uma
é um dos sintomas que podem acontecer
com o intestino hiper permeável
a Viviane aqui Viviane ou vivini deve
ser Viviane né Tem Hashimoto e
fibromialgia e tirou o glúten Parabéns
Viviane eh não sei se você tirou o leite
derivado mas também seria uma boa ideia
tá Leite comum né porque o leite casina
dois ou queijo casina dois
esporadicamente você pode
utilizar boa sugestão vou eh seria a
escala de Bristol né você quer que eu
faça um vídeo posso fazer uma live sobre
escala de Bristol vou pensar no assunto
pode ser que seja uma live até curta né
porque sen não é um assunto muito
extenso Eu já falei dessa importância
aqui da vitamina D versus pth tá o
paratormônio geralmente ele cai quando a
vitamina D sobe Então é bom você ter um
paratormônio por volta de 20 a 30 né que
isso é sinal de que a sua vitamina D tá
boa Tá isso não é complicado quando
quando a vitamina D sobe o paratormônio
cai tá nem sempre tá tem sempre tem
exceção mas na maioria dos casos isso
que acontece e um paratormônio por volta
de 30 aí geralmente é o ideal pra
maioria das
pessoas sim eh várias doenças autoimunes
miram poem e ser causadas por liqu gante
por intestino hip permeável a mais comum
como eu comentei a tiroid de rachim noto
mas a Artrite reumatoide também é uma
possibilidade várias doenças autoimunes
podem começar no intestino então retire
os alimentos inflamatórios que eu
comentei se você não sabe quais são
volta o vídeo para não ficar me
repetindo toda hora aqui então você faz
as coisas que nós estamos comentando
nesse vídeo é obviamente não vai ser da
noite pro dia você vai melhorar aos
poucos e faça um acompanhamento com o
médico entenda desse assunto Tá
bom olha só aqui o depoimento da
Gabriela tá isso é bom para miram ver ó
melhorou ação de peso na cabeça melhorou
depressão porque também desinflama o
cérebro as ceses melhoraram
excelente pressão sanguínea dela
melhorou
também abraço aí pro Leopoldino paciente
nosso aqui do consultório
o stress pode diminuir a produção de
ácido clorídrico baixa do sistema
imunológico essa diminuição levar a
permeabilidade sim a baixa do ácido
clorídrico pode sim levar e desencadear
ser um gatilho pro liqu Gate porque
aumenta a proliferação de bactérias e aí
como eu já falei excesso de bactérias
também é uma causa de de liqu gante
intestino hiper permeável
Ok o estress como eu falei é um fator
que leva ao liqu
Gut abraço
Angélica Alguém disse que a
diverticulite era igual a
hiperpermeabilidade intestinal não são
coisas diferentes tá a diverticulite é
assim conforme vai envelhecendo o
intestino grosso especialmente em
pessoas que têm dieta ruim maus hábitos
ele vai eh ficando cansado digamos assim
de fazer a contração muscular então o
músculo do intestino grosso fica com
umas falhas assim uma parte da parede
fica fraca e forma uma um dedo de luva
assim tá uma fraqueza na parede do
intestino grosso Sabe
aquela borracha que tem dentro da câmara
do pineu quando a borracha fica fraca
não faz uma Bolota assim para fora é uma
coisa parecida tá então a diverticulite
é uma inflamação nos divertículo existe
diverticulose e diverticulite
diverticulose é ter o divertículo ok Ok
e se ele inflamar se ele infeccionar aí
vira uma diverticulite Então não é assim
tem uma relação muito frouxa com a
hiperpermeabilidade intestinal porque a
hiperpermeabilidade vai est acontecendo
no Delgado e o divertículo vai tá
acontecendo no Grosso Tá mas obviamente
se você tiver muita inflamação no
intestino grosso pode acontecer que a
bactéria volta pro Delgado causa o cibo
que é proliferação de bactérias isso
pode provocar sim de depois de um tempo
uma hip
intestinal o Esse óleo que tem na
maioria das sardinhas é óleo de soja tá
E é um óleo é uma gordura inflamatória
Pode sim ser um fator de risco para
intestino permeável
então Jane não posso fazer consulta aqui
no meio da Live né você vai ter que
fazer agendar uma consulta comigo outro
médico que possa te ajudar tá Até lá
você procura ver o máximo de vídeos
possíveis que tem no canal tem mais de
1000 vídeos no canal e muitos dos vídeos
são sobre saúde intestinal tenha
perseverança Tenha fé se cuide comece a
a limpar sua dieta melhorar a atividade
física tomar mais água melhorar o Son
melhorar o estresse e veja os vídeos até
você ter condições de passar em consulta
com alguém que vá poder te ajudar
Ok
eh já já aconteceu pessoas que têm aí
uma situação muito acentuada no
intestino que emagreceram bastante né e
a gente teve que fazer aquela dieta eh
elementar por 14 dias e depois
lentamente ir regredindo esse esse
quadro então é uma situação que pode
acontecer assim de ficar bastante grave
E aí a a conduta às vezes muitas vezes é
dramática muitas vezes tem que até
internar o paciente que tá muito
debilitado tá a felizmente é meio raro
isso daí mas Mas acontece
sim
eh Gabriela bem provávelmente os
laticinios te fazem mal sim é bem
provável se você puder fazer exames para
confirmar melhor ainda tá com certeza
nunca é mas é bem
provável de novo pessoal não tem nada a
ver com lactose vocês ficam com essa
palavra lactose no cérebro eh caseína
que é o problema do Leite em relação ao
liqu gante lactose é outra coisa
intolerância à lactose que dá em adultos
que é a falta de uma enzima aí a pessoa
não consegue digerir a lactose do leite
e da diarreia e da gases Mas isso não é
eh o problema principal do leite tá
porque se você tomar leite sem lactose
você pode continuar tendo liqu Gut por
causa da
caseína Ok então obviamente quem tem
intolerância na lactose e come alimentos
com lactose vai ter mais gás vai ter
mais inflamação e pode ter também o liqu
gante tá então tanto a o lactose quanto
a casina podde ser fatores do Lick
Gut sim Evanete faça isso
tá E essa história sim eu quando eu fiz
a pos doai Ribeiro ele falava dessa
história aí do lactobacilos né e ele
deve ter lido em algum livro isso daí na
prática eu não vi eh isso daí ser
utilizado para prevenir câncer de bexiga
a melhor prevenção de câncer de bexiga é
não fumar né muito mais do que usar
qualquer tipo de yakut
tá azeite extra viig é importante porque
é uma gordura saudável né E que tem
bastante coisa nutritiva no azeite
babosa que o aloi Vera vai ajudar a
reconstituir a mucose do intestino mas
tem pessoas que TM intolerância e formam
diarreia Então tem que ser usado com
muita cautela óleo de coco também é uma
gordura saudável vinagre de maçã ele não
é bem pro liqu gante ele pode até ajudar
de uma maneira indireta diminuindo a
proliferação de bactérias Tá mas ele é
mais importante aí como controle da
glicose do
sangue desconheço se dormir após o
almoço posso ajudar o liqu Gut tá depois
eu posso dar uma pesquisada
nisso já respondi essa
aqui ajuda sim mas não é o principal
para Li Gut tá
eh se há relação entre o intestino hiper
permeável e apneia grave do Sono
desconheço essa relação tá pode pode até
ser que exista mas eu nunca vi nada a
respeito biomassa de banana verja é
muito bom como um prebiótico né É bem
interessante para saúde intestinal
Lembrando que algumas pessoas podem não
se tiver com cibo com proliferação de
bactéria no intestino
[Música]
delgado sim doença de crom vai causar
Com certeza liqu Gate tá mas aí o
tratamento é da doença de base que é a
doença de
crom eu acho que pode ajudar bastante
Carla só que só que autismo é uma
condição muito complexa é como se fosse
o vou falar aqui em termos muito
grosseiros tá pessoal por favor não me
jogue pedra mas o autismo é como se
fosse o equivalente do Alzheimer no
idoso
eh é uma inflamação no sistema nervoso
central só que na infância né enquanto
que o Alzheimer é uma neurodegeneração
que tem muito componente inflamatório no
idoso então tem alguns componentes
parecidos alguns só não é não é que é a
mesma doença pelo amor de Deus não me
interpretem mal então Con certeza os
lactobacilos mas muitas outras coisas
serão necessárias para tratar criança
com autismo como
ômega-3 suplementação
de
minerais importante também tirar os
alimentos inflamatórios o glúten o leite
fazer terapia aba fazer terapia com
fonodiólogo
então é bem complexo esse tratamento
tá olha Leonarda eu não sei o que você
quer dizer que você não encontra o
cardápio eu falei é só você procurar na
internet é tão simples isso tu vai lá
coloca lá dieta fodmap você vai ter lá
você pode comprar um livro com as
receitas culinárias do da dieta fodmap
mas eu tenho até receitas culinárias
gratuitas você pode ver a a dieta
paleolítica autoimune também tem vários
livros falando dos cardápios tá então
você tá procurando procura com um
pouquinho mais de cautela que você vai
achar pode até não achar muito cardápio
gratuito mas tá cheio de livro já cansei
de ver livro na Amazon sobre esses
assuntos tá
aqui ela tá comentando que o sono depois
do almoço não ajudaria porque tem que
ser um sono mais longo Com certeza mas
eu acho que ela tá falando se eu entendi
a pergunta dormir bem à noite e também
fazer o cochilo foi isso que eu entendi
né Já
[Música]
respondi sim pode ter prisão de Vento
por causa do cérebro ansiedade pode
provocar prisão de ventre e prisão de
ventre pode provocar ansiedade tá é
perfeitamente possível
isso veja bem Leonardo não precisa ser
uma dieta extremamente limpa isso é
importante pro celíaco se você comeu por
exemplo um pão de queijo que
Teoricamente não tem glúten mas tem
contaminação cruzada Se você não for
celíaco é muito melhor do que você por
exemplo comer um pão
ou comer uma massa que tem farinha de
trigo predominante tá então só o celíaco
que tem que se preocupar com
contaminação cruzada pessoas eh comuns
geralmente não tem esse problema sério
não sim eh pessoas que T intestino super
permeável vão ter mais inflamação e vão
ter mais eh mucos sim nas feses por
conta
disso Isso tá vendo a gab ela já
respondeu mais ou menos o que eu falei
aqui Exatamente isso é tolerante ao
glúten não é celico é diferente
tá tá aí um comentário interessante
né então clire né Deve ser clire então
clire e provavelmente vai precisar tomar
alguns terápico para melhorar a sua
situação porque obviamente tem que
avaliar o seu caso com calma com
tranquilidade mas talvez você tenha aí
Alguma proliferação bacteriana que tem
que ser
eh conduzida
Aí sim você pode fazer uso de enema de
café enema de camomila pode ajudar sim
café orgânico né E tem que lembrar que a
orgânico Não aí não é aumentar o muco
seria você melhorar a
integridade da parede e a e a
integridade da barreira de muco porque o
muco sai nas fese porque ele é descamado
né dessa barreira protetora e aumenta
nas fese mas eh você tem que na verdade
nem aumentar o muco você tem que deixar
o muco onde ele deve ficar que a parte
que protege a parede do intestino
Boa noite Estela Mares querida Estela
Mares em alguns casos pode ajudar sim
viu Jéssica tem gente que só melhorou de
problemas intestinais com a dieta
carnívora não seria a primeira dieta que
eu tentaria mas pode ser uma terceira ou
quarta opção para pessoas que são muito
refratárias
aí não não é a mesma coisa tá intestino
hiper permeável essa condição que nós
discutimos aqui na Live que muitas vezes
tá associado ao cí intestino irritável
mas a cí intestino irritável é mais
abrangente em termos conceituais do que
é o intestino hiper permeável tá então é
como se o intestino irritável quase
sempre tem intestino hiper permeável
junto só que a gente tá falando de uma
síndrome tem vários sintomas enquanto
que intestino hiper permeável é mais uma
condição patológica do que uma síndrome
dor na barriga dores na lombar pode ser
intolerância ao glúten eu tenho gastrite
essa dor não
passa sim você pode Provavelmente você
tem intestino impermeável e
provavelmente tem intestino irritável tá
aí tem que fazer avaliação o médico né e
seguir as orientações que nós falamos ao
longo dessa Live
depende Cândida Às vezes a dieta crua se
a pessoa tiver tiver hiperproliferação
bacteriana né o cibo pode até piorar em
alguns casos tá então eh na maioria dos
casos ela vai ajudar a reverter Mas isso
é
individual tem bastante comentários aqui
aleatórios tô buscando mais uma pergunta
aqui pergunta boa aqui eh unhas com
fungos significa intestino não é
impermeável hiper permeável tá
eh sim fungo é uma dos microorganismos
que pode estar associado ao intestino
hiper permeável tá que seria o cifo Né
que é o crescimento exagerado de fungo
no intestino delgado
então o pessoal pode ter cifo e muitas
vezes tem eh micose de unha Unicom
micose e mulheres pode ter vaginite de
repetição né ter candid de repetição
homens pode ter também problema no pênis
também infecção balanite de repetição
pro
fungo comentei sobre isso Leonardo se
você não pegou volte o vídeo tá já
comentei sobre
isso esse também já comentei ela pode
ajudar bastante no cibo sim tá O
ozônio não Adriano criança não quer
dizer que criança se recupera mais
rápido né mas não quer dizer que ela vai
ter menos hiperabilidade pelo contrário
se for uma criança come tranqueira ela
vai ter mais que o adulto tá
não se você comer só uma vez algo que
não faz bem não quer dizer que você vai
arrebentar Tudo de Volta não tá não é
bem assim não o intestino tem uma
capacidade de recuperação rápida tá
obviamente se você der um deslize volte
para a situação anterior de controle não
é porque você deu um deslize que você
vai desistir de tudo tá
ã tem um comentário aqui D Ana Paula que
é relevante deem uma lida aí no
comentário
dela não o pólipo intestinal não é
provocado pelo intestino hiper permeável
ele é provocado por inflamação crônica
que pode ter a ver com o intestino hiper
permeável
eh vanildes Teoricamente seria um gasto
enterologista tá mas se não for um gasto
enterologista que estudou esses assuntos
não vai adiantar nada então é melhor que
você passe com um médico funcional que
entende disso do que você passar no
gasto enterologista que não entende
disso tá pode parecer confuso mas
infelizmente essa que é a
situação já foi respondido
essa volte o vídeo se você não
pegou aqui tem uma observação também
importante D Ana
Paula Adriana eu só usaria essas enzimas
para quebrar o glúten em caso de
emergência tá não para usar no dia a dia
só se você foi numa
festa se entupiu de glutem se arrependeu
né mas pro uso no dia a dia não não
compensa hora que o comentário da Ana
Paula também que é importante
tá se você come porcaria no final de
semana você pode ter um uns dias aí de
inflamação né mas se você digamos come
todo santo final de semana pode até não
dar tempo do intestino se recuperar Tá
então não recomendo você faça todo final
de semana não tira só um dia por mês
para fazer
extravagância tá aqui um comentário da
Lu luzilene né a a casina do é
interessante para substituir o leite
comum mas eu não recomendo que Tome todo
dia também até porque ela é mais cara
serve como substituto mas para você de
vez em quando usar máximo as duas vezes
por semana aqui o comentário do Alex ou
da Alexa né não sei se é homem ou mulher
melhorou da fibromialgia por causa da
retirada do
glúten Ana Paula puxando meu saco aqui
obrigado an
Paula
eh Sim várias infecções tem relação com
com doença autoimune viu Tem muitas
evidências que vírus bactérias e fungos
podem eh servir como gatilho para
doenças autoimunes principalmente por
causa do mecanismo da do mimetismo
molecular que acontece quando esses
elementos que eu já mencionei do
intestino passam a barreira intestinal
irrita o sistema imune E provoca alta
imunidade tá através de mimetismo
molecular
llano pode ser provocado sim por
intestino permeável tá que llano é uma
doença
autoimun Paula Lembrando aqui que o
canal tem muito material não esç de
fazer pesquisa no canal porque às vezes
vocês só querem ver os vídeos novos
esquece que tem os vídeos antigos também
são muito
valiosos a maçã cozida é muito bom tá
porque tem fibras né tem a pectina da
maçã
eh Cacau favorece Porque Cacau
antiinflamatório tem um índice orac que
é um índice de antioxidação Alto canela
também muito bom cravo tem ação
antibacteriana
antifungica óleo de coco também tem ação
antibacteria antifungica tudo isso aí
pode favorecer sim intestino
saudável Obrigado aí pelo comentário
Genivaldo
Olha só o comentári da Tatiana aqui
importante para vocês aqui
ó tá vendo pessoal não sei o que eu tô
inventando isso as pessoas estão
confirmando para vocês
aí é bom tomar mas como eu expliquei
para algumas pessoas os probióticos não
descem bem se você não pegou tá no ponto
mais para trás do vídeo se deu queimação
vanildes é porque a dose tá alta demais
para você ou você não precisa de idade
betaína tá então é quando dá queimação é
porque você usou dose Alta ou você não
precisa
usar com certeza
Leonardo provavelmente eu não fala CL ou
Claire porque é uma doença que não é tão
comum e aí as pessoas querem fazer
vídeos que as pessoas se interessam em
assistir né ninguém quer fazer um vídeo
para 10 gato pingado assistir tá deve
ser por isso que você a sua frustração é
totalmente compreensível eu entendo isso
Mas veja pelo lado do produtor de
conteúdo ele quer produzir material que
vai interessar o maior número de pessoas
né porque as pessoas eh que estão
gerando conteúdo precisa ter
uma um respaldo né de de de retorno de
audiência
tem vários exames para doença selica
anti
transglutaminase an antigliadina né o
hla dq2 dq8 tá eh São exames você pode
fazer uma pesquisa depois eh com mais
calma sobre esses exames para doença
celíaca e também tem a biópsia de
intestino delgado que faz por endoscopia
que é o diagnóstico definitivo do celica
não é uma dança comum pessoal do celica
dá em 1% da população já a intolerância
não celica ao glúten é muito mas muito
mais comum tá para mais aí de 40% da
população tem isso daí e para quem tem
problema intestinal pode colocar uns
70% é faz sentido né com tempo pode
acontecer ass a perda das da das das
velocidades intestinais Mas isso
acontece com mais intensidade de doença
inflamatória mais grave
tá pessoal não tem paciência
né É porque o Eliseu ele já deixa 300
perguntas no começo da Live E aí eu fui
seguindo a ordem entendeu vocês me
desculpem mas é como tinha perguntas
boas da parte dele eu fui respondendo
porque serve para outras pessoas também
mas vocês não têm paciência pessoal
Calma né
[Música]
ah
ã tem uns comentario zinhos
aqui qual melhor quefir você quer dizer
se é quefir de leite ou quefir de água é
essa que a tua pergunta tem quefir de
água quefir de leite quefir de leite de
coco né né acho quef de leite coco
Talvez seja o melhor
né
[Música]
Hã Tem sim Marcelo dá uma procurada lá
no
canal tá vendo o que eu falei ó Tem
pessoas que não se dão bem Com
lactobacilo e probiótico
né Isso aí é porque provavelmente essa
pessoa aí Ana Paula tem prov tem
cibo colostro é uma coisa interessante
para reduzir inflamação intestinal sim
tá colostro para quem não sabe é o
primeiro leite que sai ali do do animal
se for uma vaca ou se for um porco né ou
no caso do ser humano né da mãe né o
primeiro leite que sai é um leite que
tem
bastante imunoglobulinas né anticorpos é
interessante PR pela ação
antiinflamatória que
tem não é impermeabilidade é hiper
hiperpermeabilidade Tá sim pode ser
causado por
vbn tá a pessoa utilizou o oile
e bicarbonato melhorou
do do rimoto sei se foi isso que eu
entendi
[Música]
ah pode ter a ver rut pode ter a ver
porque a c da pernas inquietas é uma
inflamação e pode ser provocada por não
é a única causa mas é pode ser uma uma
das uma das causas pode ser
hiperabilidade intestinal né e a insônia
também ã que
mais melhor magnésio para intestino
hiper permeável
ã Então vai depender se a pessoa tiver
muita constipação vai ser o cloreto de
magnésio ou citrato de magnésio se a
pessoa tiver intestino solto é melhor
usar o magnésio quelado tá ou
glicina tá vai ser
melhor pode sim a dieta ketoflex na
verdade é uma dieta muito parecida com a
dieta
eh paleolítica autoimune tá tem muita
semelhança
tô selecionando aqui pessoal as coisas
mais
relevantes Olha só esse comentário aqui
pode ser importante para
vocês obrigado pelo comentário Erica um
beijo para
você o butirato é muito interessante ele
ele na verdade é um ácido gráfic de
cadeia curta ele vai ajudar na saúde do
intestino grosso e ele pode ser bem
interessante para pessoas aí que têm
disbiose intestinal butirato não é
específico para intestino hiper
permeável mas ele pode ajudar bastante
algumas pessoas aí
tá pode ser Ana pode
ser gente eu já falei isso aqui no
começo da Live é porque vocês ficam
perguntando e não prestam atenção na
Live né Ah volta o vídeo
Elsa eu respondi isso aqui eu falei que
a ansiedade pode interferir no intestino
o intestino pode interferir no cérebro
tá bom assiste o vídeo de novo desde o
começo e prestando
atenção obrigado viu pelo comentário
sim pode ajudar porque muito dos
princípios ativos lá do protocolo da rud
clarque não é só antibacteriano mas
também antifúngico e desculpa não é só
antiparasitário mas antibacteriano e
antifungico
também
zeólita se você usar por bastante tempo
ele pode ajudar a eliminar vírus e
bactérias também mas tomar cuidado que
você pode perder minerais importantes
com uso eh constante de
zeólita só se for autohemoterapia com
ozônio tá autohemoterapia sem ozônio eu
creio que não
tá leite de pso nunca usei não tá nunca
usei esse leite de panço posso até
depois pesquisar mais a respeito
ma hálito tá principalmente relacionado
à boca tá foco dentário mais higiene
bocal eh algum tipo de bactéria que pode
estar se desenvolvendo em cavitações ou
então em canais mas existe uns 20% de
chance desse ma á ser por causa do
intestino ou estômago
Ok gente essa Live aqui tá bombando né
tanta pergunta aqui tá ficando até
cansado já tem 1 hora e13
Eu acho que eu vou encerrar com 20 tá
para não ficar muito longa essa
Live isso aí Leonardo façam isso pessoal
ajudem o canal outra coisa pessoal
ajudem o canal canal soft boot já tem
bastante tempo vocês por favor divulguem
os vídeos pros seus amigos e familiares
não tenha preguiça pega lá o link joga
no grupo do WhatsApp joga num post no
Instagram joga num post no Facebook
pessal é importante ajudar o canal e
ajudar as pessoas mais do que me ajudar
tá ajudando as pessoas porque eu tô
dando conhecimento de graça PR as
pessoas
tá ácido butírico na manteiga sim tem
ácido butílico na manteiga Sim esta Live
vai ficar salva a pergunta
que sempre é feita desde o início da
humanidade né se a Live vai ficar salva
a resposta é sim Taiane a Live vai ficar
salva viu fique
tranquila dor de barriga toda semana
seguida de nause e malestar o que
será pode ser um monte de coisa
inclusive parasita né
gastrite atrófica
autoimune a causa é justamente eh a
gastrite atrófica ela é já deu a causa é
autoimune tá E é a causa dela pode estar
relacionada a liqu gante também mas não
tem uma causa definitiva porque que
causou autoimunidade mas o liqu gante
pode ser os mecanismos
envolvidos
ah Cadê char de Damiana é bom pro
testino hiper permeável não sei Cândida
sinceramente eu não sei nunca li nada a
respeito
Obrigado
eh pessoal eu acho que eu vou encerrar
por agora consegui ver a maioria aqui
Dos comentários se por acaso eu não
respondi alguma pergunta sua Pode ser
que a sua pergunta tava não relacionada
ao tema eu eu tive
a
preocupação de responder às dúvidas
pertinentes ao ao tema tá bom E outra
coisa pessoas tentando tirar
diagnósticos assim coisa que eu não
posso fazer numa Live
né aqui é uma pergunta interessante a
hiperpermeabilidade intestinal provoca
alergias sim pode ser um fator gatilho
para alergia Sim ok Mas ân tamí eu já
tinha respondido a pergunta anterior da
Sara Lancaster mas pode ter tá
relacionado a algia
também bem pessoal Muito obrigado pela
presença de vocês não esqueçam
de divulgar esse vídeo paraos seus
amigos e familiares tá não ten a
preguiça de fazer isso e eu vou divulgar
também para vocês que eu vou estou
lançando agora essa semana e nas
seguintes um curso
sobre tratamento natural da hipoplasia
prostática benigna é um curso sobre
tratamento natural com fitoterapia e
minerais e suplementos para a próstata
grande é um curso super completo mais
completo que existe na
internet que é fruto de muito estudo e
também de muita prática no consultório
então tem os dois aspectos bem abordados
ali tanto a parte teórica quanto a
parte prática e é um curso que é voltado
a Profissionais de Saúde especialmente
médicos e
nutricionistas mas o curso não tá
restrito ele não vai ficar bloqueado só
para quem tem CRM ou c ou ou CRN tá eh
só que pessoas que queiram fazer esse
curso muito avançado assim muito
completo tem que ter um conhecimento eh
mínimo digamos assim se são pessoas
inteligentes e são esforçadas Pode até
ser alguém que não fez medicina ou não
fez nutrição pode fazer esse curso Mas
diferente do curso prosta blindada que
eu lancei anos atrás em parceria com a
jolivi esse curso é muito mais
aprofundado do que aquele curso que eu
tinha lançado anos atrás que era para
leigos tá então me ajude a divulgar esse
curso sobre
próstata tratamento natural da próstata
crescida da próstata grande nas próximas
semanas vocês vão ver eu falando
bastante desse curso ok
Então pessoal de novo divulguem esse
vídeo paraa maioria das pessoas que
vocês possam entender que vão se
beneficiar com esse conteúdo ajudem a
gente a divulgar o bem a divulgar a
palavra para que mais pessoas sejam
beneficiadas ajudem também a esse canal
a transpor a bolha que foi colocado a
restrição que foi colocado
eh para que esse canal possa atingir
cada vez mais pessoas um grande abraço
vocês até a próxima um beijo no coração
e vocês são pera